- This video is brought
to you by LetsGetChecked.
(intro music)
(liquid pouring)
What's up, guys, Michael here.
So I just finished the final season
of FX's mind blowing series, Legion,
and walked away with,
well, a lot of thoughts.
And that's a good thing.
It's the story of David
Haller, an almost all-powerful,
ESP-fueled mutant, who also
happens to be a schizophrenic,
and it leans hard into
the nonsensical, bizarre,
and just plain weird.
It's got multiple reality-bending scenes,
wild off the wall musical
numbers and dance-offs,
and with the addition of
season three, time travel.
They're also pretty
self-aware about it too,
with episode recaps
often starting like this.
- [Narrator] Evidently on Legion.
Ostensibly on Legion.
- But with so much going on,
it's a little hard to pry out
one coherent show defining philosophy.
Which always gets us asking,
is the show smart,
or does it just think it is?
Well, that's what we're here to find out.
Welcome to this episode
on Legion: Deep or Dumb?
And ostensibly, spoilers ahead.
But before we get into it,
I wanna give a shout
out to LetsGetChecked.
An at home testing
service with the mission
to make health screening
open, and patient led.
If you're anything like me,
you know that it's almost impossible
to carve out time to go to the doctor.
Their available appointments
always seem to be on Wednesday at 2 PM
On the other side of town.
Still, I know how important it
is to keep tabs on my health.
One test almost everyone
I know is afraid to take
is a sexual health check.
In fact, 51% of people
don't get tested for STD's
because they don't want to
bring up sex with their doctor.
Enter LetsGetChecked.
LetsGetChecked offers a variety
of general wellness tests
for men and women.
Which includes things
like fertility tests,
hormone test and STD test.
It's really important to make
sure that you get tested.
And with LetsGetChecked, you can skip
that awkward visit to the Doctor,
and do it right from the
comfort of your own home.
You just go online,
order the kit and it will be delivered
in a discreet package within a few days,
then you activate it online,
follow the instructions
and send back your sample
with the prepaid label.
Once your results are available online,
a LetsGetChecked team of
Physicians and Nurses are available
to discuss your results on the phone
and can prescribe
medication when appropriate.
You can get your own STD kit,
or explore all their kit options today,
by clicking the link in the description,
or by clicking here.
If you use Promo Code Wisecrack,
you can get 20% off.
Now back to the show.
First, a quick primer on the show.
And yeah, try to keep up.
Season one introduces us to David Haller.
Who his whole life has
been told that he's insane.
But after being rescued
from the governments grasp,
by a group of like minded mutants.
David learns that he
actually has psychic powers.
And begins training to control his power.
The only problem is that a
powerful telepath, Amahl Farouk,
has been lodged in his
brain since he was a baby.
And is now is trying
to take over his mind.
Well season one ends with
Farouk being kicked out
of David's brain.
Season two focuses on the
group trying to kill him.
Except not really, because
we learn that David
is actually kind of an evil asshole.
Not above torturing a
friend to get what he wants
or raping his girlfriend Sydney Barrett.
In one of televisions
biggest bait and switches,
season two ends with the
group befriending Farouk,
and hunting David.
Fast forward a few months,
where season three picks up.
David has decided to live a quiet life
as a cult leader for young
women with abandonment issues.
- We?
- [David] My people.
- Your commune?
Are you talking about your commune,
where you seduce teenage
girls with daddy issues?
- [Michael] That is
until the time traveler,
Switch, arrives.
But David's not interested
in going back in time
and righting his wrong.
Instead, he wants to
go so far back in time,
that he stops Amhal Farouk
from ever inhabiting his
brain in the first place.
In the process stopping all the literal
madness that has occurred since.
The only problem is that Switch's powers
aren't fully developed yet.
And by going so far back in time,
David has angered some
seriously creepy baddies.
- In the hall of time, there are demons.
- Wait, demons?
- [Michael] Still, David
and Switch keep at it,
which causes some disastrous consequences
for the present, like, oh right,
potentially ending the world.
- This is how he does it.
- [Michael] While Sydney and the others
race backwards in time to stop David
from doing anymore damage,
David meets up with
his father in the past.
Telepath, Charles Xavier of X Men fame.
And teams up with him to kill Farouk.
Except future Farouk joins the mix,
and convinces Charles that
violence isn't the answer.
After one touching father son moment,
and a slightly less
touching, but still moving
past future Farouk moment,
everyone comes to an understanding.
- I'm saying that war is not the answer,
it's the problem, David we
don't need this barbarism,
I've made a deal with Farouk.
- Are you saying we just leave?
- I'm saying that we respect their right
to exist and they respect ours, yours.
- With the past successfully changed,
David and Sydney look over
the crib at baby David,
before they both disappear into the ether.
Having effectively erased their
own existences, and scene.
Now if all of that doesn't seem
perfectly clear to you, don't panic.
From the get go,
Legion has always been about challenging
the audiences expectations,
and season three is no different.
Simply put, it's confusing.
What does it all mean?
Well, here's our two best takes.
Idea One: Metaphor & Metaphysics.
In case it wasn't immediately obvious,
Legion thrives on an
ambiguous sense of reality.
Throughout the shows three seasons,
we are constantly asking ourselves,
what is real or true?
Is David Haller really David,
or is he the host of other
personalities inside his head?
- Who the hell are you?
- I am Legion.
- I am Legion
- [Michael] Is Amhal Farouk really evil?
Or is he actually a
loving surrogate father?
- I love the boy Charles.
- As it turns out, much of this ambiguity
stems from the shows
unabashed love for metaphors.
But when we say metaphor,
we're not just talking about
simply comparing two things.
But a very specific
philosophical sense of the word.
Borrowing from the work of
philosopher Richard Moran,
we can say that,
Metaphors create a sense of Ambiguity
because of the framing
effects they produce.
In Moran's view, metaphors force people
to consider and object or
situation in a new light,
by contrasting it with another.
Importantly, this framing
isn't fixed nor is its meaning.
And this is where our ambiguity creeps in.
When the show calls Farouk
a monster for example,
this could mean anything,
from the fact that he's
technically an alien life form,
to the fact that he's incredibly powerful,
to the fact that he once
trapped a king's mind
inside that of a monkeys.
- By monster, you mean
like a metaphor, right?
- As philosopher Donald
Davidson points out.
Most metaphors don't
possess definite meanings
anymore than dreams do.
After all, when Romeo
compares Juliet to the sun,
there are a million and one
different things it could mean.
In the same way that dreaming you're naked
in front of your high school class
could mean both everything, and nothing.
But what's important here is
by framing Juliet with the sun,
we're creating an infinite
amount of associations.
According to Davidson,
just like in dreams,
a metaphor's meaning is interpretive.
At its best, the dream like
logic behind metaphors,
really does drive home,
how ambiguous Legion's reality really is.
Take season two, in which
episodes often begin
with an educational segment
that later contextualizes
the action on screen.
- [Narrator] Psychologists
call it a conversion disorder.
In that the body converts a mental stress
to a set of physical symptoms,
in this case, a tick or spasm.
And like any disorder
it can be contagious.
- At first these segments
seem to contextualize
our understanding of the
various telepathic phenomenon
going on in the show.
The spread of our teeth
clacking zombies, for example.
(teeth clacking)
Is compared to the way
conversion disorders
like laughing fits and mass hysterics
have spread throughout history.
In another segment,
delusions are characterized
like parasites,
feeding on rational ideas,
until only they are left.
This in turn, later explains
the spread of delusion
among the members of division three.
That an admiral must be killed.
- I'll have our rumors, whisperers,
people go to Admiral Fukuyama's pedestal.
And they don't come back.
- What does he do to them?
- He eats them.
- [Speaker System] System Alert.
- It's not gonna happen to us.
- In both cases these
metaphors seem to contain
fairly simple meanings.
Madness is contagious and
delusion is destructive.
But of course, meaning is a
moving target with metaphors.
And reality is constantly shifting
under your feet in Legion.
While we spend a whole
season thinking we understand
what these metaphors mean,
the last episode of season two,
really rips the rug from
underneath our collective feet.
The madness that had been spreading,
the delusion that had been growing.
It was David, and boy, were we wrong.
- David Haller, your
treachery has been discovered,
the inevitability of your future crimes.
- [Michael] However, while
the end of season two
might have been a high point for Legion's
thematic use of metaphors.
Season three demonstrates how sometimes
the show can collapse
under a metaphors weight.
Because lets be real here,
some metaphors like dreams,
make zero sense at all.
I think the best example of this would be
season three's depiction
of the astral plane.
As if it was purposefully
designed to give us a headache.
The astral plane is both a
literal and metaphorical place.
Amhal Farouk at one point gives us
this no nonsense definition of it,
well at least by Legions standards.
- This is the astral plane,
a world beyond the world.
Made of pure energy.
Very few can see it.
- [Michael] Meanwhile
Jermaine, I mean Oliver,
tells us that the astral plane
is kinda like the island of misfit toys.
Where broken minds, forgotten truths
and lost objects all collect.
- We were always finding things.
Pins, poetry, socks.
The astral plane was like
a magnet for lost dreams.
Minds, that was the other thing we found.
In the real world, when
people lost their minds,
they ended up here.
- On the surface,
we're presented with
an interesting problem.
How can a metaphorical place,
where literal lost dreams come true,
also be a real place?
And what does this tell us
about the larger logic motivating Legion?
Well one way we could go
about this is to assume
that both the physical
and mental properties
are equally real in the show.
If thoughts and matter all contain some,
for lack of a better word, mental stuff,
then it goes a long way in explaining
how a metaphorical world
like the astral plane,
can double as a real physical place.
So, for example, while we might
usually think of being
heartbroken as an emotional state,
in the astral plane,
you could literally find the embodiment
of your broken heart,
bleeding out in the street.
- Don't forget your heart.
- [Michael] By having these mental states
manifest themselves physically
in the astral plane,
the show seems to be advocating
for a sort of panpsychic doctrine.
Distilled into its most basic component,
panpsychism holds at
the old Cartesian divide
between mind and body, isn't
really a divide at all.
Instead, the pansychist
believes that everything
from the glass in your smart phone,
to the neurons in your brain,
contains fundamental mental elements.
Now before you start worrying that
the ground beneath your feet has feelings.
(squealing)
- Pansychists usually
don't commit to the idea
that everything has thoughts.
Instead, most believe that everything
has a mental experience.
The mental experience of a
human might be quite complex,
while that of a fly might be much simpler,
and that of a rock would
be even more basic.
To most panpsychists, mental experience
is a fundamental building
block of the universe.
With actual thought only being achieved
by sufficiently complex entities.
Applying this model to Legion,
we can see how both
regular everyday objects
and abstract ideas, like
the loss of innocence,
appear in the astral plane.
They all have a mental experience.
It also goes a long way in
explaining why David struggles
to differentiate between
his mind and reality.
They're all made of the
same mental building blocks.
- His mind is fixed, his
reality is alternate.
- [Michael] But while
this is an interesting
hook into the show,
it's hard to say if the show
is really using panpsychism
or metaphors to make any deeper arguments
about the nature of reality or experience.
When it comes to panpsychism,
the show never seems to really draw out
any of the implications of
having reality and your mind
being both equally real.
Especially in regards to David.
And when it comes to metaphor,
it sometimes feels like
the show is confusing
for the sake of being confusing.
Sure, in an over saturated
superhero market,
it might be fun to see musical
numbers stand in for dialog.
- There's only one way this can end,
a rap battle.
- [Michael] But sometimes
we like to understand
the literal narrative.
After all, according to
playwright and screenwriter
David Mamet, the core of drama is about,
finding previously
unsuspected meaning in chaos,
the truth that had been
previously obscured by lies.
But maybe we should be okay
with Legion's uneven use of metaphor.
For a show that's so out there
in terms of art direction,
maybe all the metaphors are just a way
to tell an interesting story.
Philosophy be damned.
Going back to our philosophers
Moran and Davidson.
Metaphors don't necessarily
have to make sense.
The important thing is the effect.
The framing.
And effects seems to be Legions m.o.
it's all about that style.
So maybe we should forgive
the show for pelting us
with various dance
numbers, loquacious asides.
- It's about the order of things.
The order you learn when you're
young, we let you be wild,
because wildness is important,
but as you grow older
we give you structure.
So you'd feel safe.
- [Michael] And the
very weird astral plane.
♪ I'm the supine lupine
my libido kills sunshine ♪
♪ Moody and spicy like a
fine ass toilet wine. ♪
- Maybe all Legion is trying
to do is keep it interesting.
So deep, maybe not.
Idea Two: Time & Change.
Of course the big shake
up in season three,
other than Ptonomy's mustache.
Is the addition of the
time traveler, Switch.
Now it might seem unfair
to put Legion's depiction of time travel
under the microscope.
When it comes to comic book characters
we kind of just have to
grant the initial premise.
Radioactive spiders giving you superpowers
instead of cancer?
Sure, why not.
And early on, Legion playfully reminds us
that its depiction of time travel
isn't going to trey to heavily on science.
- What do you know about time travel?
- I have a PhD in quantum mechanics
and a masters in nuclear physics.
- Have you ever seen the hall?
- The hall?
- Time is a hallway, it
moves in two directions,
forwards and back,
and by drawing a doorway
in the air, like this,
I can access the time stream.
- But there has to be some
internal logic going on, right?
Well in Legion's case, not really.
In fact, the final season
continually fails to address
one of the biggest logical
problems in time travel.
The grandfather paradox.
That is, how can time travel be possible
if you went back in time,
killed your grandfather and
made sure you were never born
to go back in time and
kill said grandfather.
Now, there are a lot of
ways to tackle this problem.
You could go the Marvel
route and just say,
no matter what you do while
swanning around in the past
the future doesn't change.
- Time doesn't work that
way, changing the past
doesn't change the future.
- [Michael] As for Legion,
the show's solution
can best be summed up as (bleep) it,
come at me bro.
(foreign language)
- [Michael] Yeah, so
David does successfully
change his past by keeping
his parents together
and saving his baby
self from Amahl Farouk.
In doing so, he literally
erases his current self.
- So now what?
We just sort of.
- Fade away, into the ether.
- How does this square with the fact,
that if David hadn't shared his brain
with Farouk for 33 years,
he wouldn't have gone back
in time in the first place?
It doesn't.
But maybe Legion isn't trying
to make a logical argument
about time travel.
Maybe this aspect of the story,
as trippy and sometimes
nonsensical as it is,
is in service of a larger message.
We're brought back to
the idea of metaphor.
The beginning of Legions final episode.
Starts with this text
flashing across the screen.
This is the end, the beginning, the end.
what it all means is not for us to know.
It is for history to decide.
All we can do is play
the parts as written.
All we can know is ourselves.
On the surface of it
it seems strange for Legion
to frame the final episode with a quote.
After all if David and company
are just playing their parts
as written, how are they
supposed to change the past?
And what does self knowledge
have to do with, well, anything?
But what if this text is a metaphor?
Asking us to reframe everything we've seen
in three seasons,
according to these words.
In this case, the show hints
that everything David has done,
past and present from being born,
to cartoon fighting Amhal Farouk,
has been necessary.
That David needed to quiet
literally experience time
in order for him to change,
and thereby save the world.
And while it might seem
like we're reaching here,
this theory does fit with
the rest of the show.
In fact the idea that characters
needed to experience time to change,
is integral to all our major players art.
Syd for example must
live a second childhood
in the astral plane,
under the watch of Oliver and Melanie.
She goes from the
understandably rage-filled girl
shooting her rapist, to a
kickass self actualized woman
who knows how to save the world.
- I know honey.
But here's the thing,
the real world needs you.
All those bad things,
they don't have to be bad.
They can be fixed.
- Likewise, the 30 plus
years Amhal Farouk spent
in Davids head has changed him.
- I saw what he saw, I felt what he felt,
I thought what he thought.
And over time, what was once
a prison became a person.
- [Michael] When present Farouk
finally sizes up his past self,
he can barely contain the contempt
for the person he once was.
(foreign language)
- You have become soft in your old age.
Was I really this miserable
and filled with hate?
How petty you seem.
- [Michael] But what about
David, does he really change?
According to our girl Syd,
there's no saving the present David.
He's broken goods.
- David, adult David, we can't save him,
he's too far gone.
But a baby, this baby, him we can save.
- [Michael] So how does
time help David change?
Quite literally by
unwriting his existence.
Listen to this narration
David gives in the beginning
of the final episode.
Again it serves to reframe
everything we've seen
up to this point in the show.
- [Narrator] Lessons in
time travel, chapter zero.
Who we were does not
dictate who we will be.
But often, it's a pretty good indication.
Time travel does not give one
the opportunity to change ones self.
But rather to eradicate ones self.
And allow something
else to form in the wake
of what once was.
- [Michael] In other
words, change for David
could only come through destruction.
And he could only achieve that destruction
by messing with time.
It's madness, and it's a complete twist
on how other characters experience time
in order to change, but
madness is David's m.o.
Finally, in the closing
minutes of the show,
Legion seems to suggest,
that there's almost a
cosmic plan to this change.
Whether it's Sydney's second childhood,
or David's suicide gamble.
When Switch dies in the final episode,
it's revealed that she's not human at all,
but quite literally the
embodiment of time itself.
- How do you know?
- I am time, I see all.
- [Michael] When Switch
returns back to Earth,
she lets everyone know
that there was meaning
to the change they underwent.
That Switch, as the embodiment of time
and the universe itself
has validated them.
- Sydney Barrett, Gabriel
Xavier and the Infant David,
the universe acknowledges you,
that you exist, and that
your existence is important.
I can see that you've suffered.
That people you love have suffered.
And you want to know
that it meant something.
It did, it does.
Nothing of value is ever lost.
- And even though the
present them will perish,
it was also better versions of themselves
shall flourish in their place.
So what do we make of Legion's
take on time and change?
Again, I think it's best to invoke
Davidson's work on metaphor here.
As Davidson rightly points out.
How many facts are
conveyed by a photograph?
None, an infinity, or one
great unstatable fact?
Bad question.
A picture is not worth a thousand words,
or any other number.
Words are the wrong currency
to exchange for a picture.
In the same way, holding
Legion's take on time and change
to a philosophical standard
might not be the right approach.
At the end of the day,
Noah Holley decided to not make
a philosophical argument with the show,
but rather an artistic one.
And like in time travel,
in this choice there is a
sort of grace or madness.
Whatever deeper meaning there is here,
if any at all, this show's
not giving us any hints.
Overall we give Legion a 5/10 for smarts.
But hey, maybe we're just not getting it.
Thanks for watching guys, peace.
(upbeat music)